so we proceed to the statement by the
minister of State for immigration Robert
generick
with permission man on depth of speaker
I'd like to make a statement on illegal
migration three months ago my right on a
friend the Prime Minister set out a
comprehensive plan to tackle illegal
migration we said we would act and we
have we've increased immigration
enforcement visits to their highest
levels in recent years since December
more than three and a half thousand
enforcement visits have been carried out
and more than 4 000 people with no right
to be here have been removed and French
Corporation is now closer than ever
before and will be deepened because of
the deal struck by the Prime Minister
earlier this month we've expanded our
partnership with Rwanda to include the
relocation of all those who pass through
safe countries to make illegal and
dangerous Journeys to the United Kingdom
our modern slavery reforms introduced as
part of the nationality and borders act
to prevent those who seek to abuse our
generosity from doing so are bearing
fruit we're tackling the backlog with
our Asylum system by cutting unnecessary
paperwork and simplifying country
guidance as a result productivity has
increased and we're on track to process
the backlog of initial Asylum Decisions
by the end of the year Madam Deputy
speaker we must ensure our laws enable
us to deal with the global migration
crisis which is why we have brought
forward the illegal migration bill
the bill goes further than any previous
immigration legislation to fix the
problem of small boats whilst remaining
within the boundaries of our treaty
obligations and of course
Asylum system we will continue to honor
our country's specific and Global safe
and legal commitments
but we cannot and will not stop here
Madam Deputy speaker because illegal
migration continues to impact the
British public in their day-to-day lives
the sheer number of small boats have
overwhelmed our Asylum system and forced
the government to place Asylum seekers
in hotels
these hotels
take valuable assets from communities
and place pressures on local public
services
Seaside towns have lost tourist trade
weddings have been canceled and local
councils have had their resources
diverted to manage them and the
hard-working British taxpayer has been
left to foot the eye-watering 2.3
billion pound a year Bill Madam Deputy
speaker we must not Elevate the
well-being of illegal migrants above
those of the British people
it is in their interests that we are
sent here
the enduring solution
to stop the boats
is to take the actions outlined in our
bill but in the meantime it is right
that we act to correct the Injustice of
the current situation
I have heard time and again of councils
up and down the country struggling to
accommodate arrivals this is no easy
task the government recognizes that
placing Asylum Seekers into local areas
comes at a cost
and so central government will now
provide further financial support today
we're announcing a new funding package
which includes generous additional per
bed payments and continuation of the
funding for every new dispersal bed
available
we will also pilot an additional
incentive payment where those properties
are made available faster
but faced with the scale of the
challenge we must fundamentally alter
our posture towards those who seek to
enter our country illegally
this government remains committed to
meeting our legal obligations to those
who would otherwise be destitute
but we're not prepared to go further
accommodation for migrants should meet
their essential living needs and nothing
more
because we cannot risk becoming a magnet
for the millions of people who are
displaced and seeking better economic
prospects
many of our European partners are
struggling with the same issue Belgium
Ireland Germany and France are having to
take similar steps and the UK must adapt
to this changing context
I've said before that we have to suffuse
our entire system with deterrence and
this must include how we house illegal
migrants
so today the government is announcing
the first tranche of sites we will set
up to provide basic accommodation at
scale
the government will use military sites
being disposed of in Essex and
Lincolnshire and a separate site in East
Sussex
these will be scaled up over the coming
months and will collectively provide
accommodation to several thousand Asylum
Seekers through repost repurposed
Barrett blocks and Porter cabins
in addition my right home a friend the
prime minister is showing leadership on
this issue by bringing forward proposals
to provide accommodation at catterick
Garrison barracks in his constituency
and we're continuing to explore the
possibility of accommodating migrants in
vessels as they are in Scotland and in
the Netherlands
Madam Deputy speaker I want to be clear
these sites on their own will not end
the use of hotels overnight
but alongside local dispersal and other
forms of accommodation which we will
bring forward in due course they will
relieve pressure on our communities and
they will manage Asylum seekers in a
more appropriate and cost effective way
of course we recognize the concerns of
local residents
and we're acutely aware of the need to
minimize the impact of these sites on
communities
basic Healthcare will be available
around the clock Security will be
provided on site and our providers will
work closely with local police and other
partners funding will be provided to
local authorities in which these sites
are located
Madam Deputy speaker these sites are
undoubtedly in the National interest we
have to deliver them if we're to stop
the use of hotels we have to deliver
them to save the British public from
spending eye-watering amounts
accommodating illegal migrants and we
have to deliver them
to prevent a pull factor
for economic migrants on the continent
taking hold
on Deputy speaker in action is not an
option the British people rightly want
us to tackle illegal migration
as I've set out today we are doing
exactly that and I commend this
statement to the house
Shadow Secretary of State Yvette Copa
thank you madam Deputy speaker
my Deputy speaker today's statement is
an admission of failure maybe that's why
the Home Secretary has asked the
immigration minister to make it instead
four years ago the cabinet said they
would halve Channel Crossings they've
gone up 20-fold since then a year ago
they said they'd end Hotel use they've
opened more than ever they keep making
new announcements but it just keeps
getting worse and people want to see
strong border security and properly
managed Asylum and Refugee systems so
that the UK does its bit to help those
fleeing persecution and conflict
alongside other countries but we have
got neither of those at the moment
there's no point in blaming everyone
else because they are in charge the
Asylum system is broken because they
broke it they have let criminal gangs
rip along the Channel people Smuggler
convictions have halved in the last four
years even though more boats and more
gangs have been Crossing and yet Tory
MPS last yesterday voted against his
plan for cross-border police units to go
after the gangs they've let Asylum
decision making collapse we've had a big
increase in staff but 40 percent fewer
cases being decided so they failed to
take basic decisions and they're still
not doing labors plan to fast-track last
year's arrivals from Albania and other
safe countries and as for today's
announcements we need to end costly and
inappropriate Hotel use but these plans
don't do that the ministers had to admit
contrary to all of the briefing in the
papers this morning who won't attend end
Hotel use instead these sites are
additional and Minister should have been
finding cheaper sites and properly
managing costs years ago today's damning
report from the government's own
independent Watchdog which strangely the
minister did not mention today says
there's been no cost control that the
home office contracts are highly
inefficient no cross-government
transparency and oversight officials
didn't have financial information on the
contracts they were signing didn't
compare and most ludicrously of all and
I quote different parts of the home
office operating different schemes at
times found themselves competing for the
same Hotel contract driving prices up
totally chaotic basically they've
written a whole load of checks in a
panic if they had put that money into
clearing the backlog instead we wouldn't
be in this mess now and they should have
been working with councils to do this
but they didn't yesterday Tory MPS again
voted against Labor's plans for a legal
requirement for councils to be consulted
instead he has conservative councils
backed by conservative MPS taking action
against him so can he confirm that the
foreign secretary is backing legal
action against the Home Secretary
frankly that is a first even for this
chaotic government and the bill makes
things worse no returns agreements with
France or Europe the Prime Minister has
just said the Home Secretary was wrong
the Rwanda flights won't start this
summer they've nowhere to send people to
and instead of speeding up Asylum
decisions they're just going to cancel
them so that means more people in Asylum
accommodation and hotels and more
flim-flam headlines that just don't
stack up today it was barges and it
turns out there aren't any desperate to
distract everyone from the damage they
might want to do to the dambusters
Heritage instead they start talking
about ferries and barges three years ago
they said the same thing last summer the
Prime Minister said it would be cruise
liners the home office civil servant
said ferries would end up costing more
than the hotels they're already spending
so much money on so instead the
immigration Minister has been sent round
the country with a copy of waterways
weekly trying to find barges instead and
he still hasn't found any so can he tell
us are these sites then going to be
additional not instead of Hotel use will
he still be using more hotels or less
for Asylum seekers in six months time of
the 45
000 people the boat arrivals last year
can he confirm that more than 90 percent
of decisions have not been taken because
the backlog is still their failure and
we apologize for their failure on cost
control they failed to support neighbors
plan to go after the gangs get a new
agreement with France and to fast-track
decisions and returns they are flailing
around in a panic chasing headlines
barges oil rigs Rwanda flights even wave
machines instead of doing the hard graft
they have lost control of our border
security lost control of the Asylum
system lost control of their budget and
lost control of themselves will he
answer my questions on would he get a
grip yeah
well isn't it abundantly clear Madame
Deputy speaker that labor don't have the
faintest clue how to tackle this issue
they have absolutely no plan what we've
laid out today is three months of
intense work which is seeing the backlog
coming down productivity Rising more
sustainable forms of accommodation a
harder approach to make it difficult to
live a work in the UK illegally illegal
working raids and visits Rising by 50
greater control over the Channel all
improvements as a result of the ten
point plan that my right honorable
friends the Prime Minister and the Home
Secretary set out the honor the right
honorable lady
looks back to a mythical time when labor
were last in office when the home office
by their own home secretary who was
deemed to be not fit for purpose they
call for more safe and legal routes even
though we are second only to Sweden in
Europe for resettlement schemes they
call for more money for law enforcement
although we've doubled the funding of
the National Crime agency and our people
are out there Upstream tackling
organized immigrational immigration
criminals every day of the week and
isn't it extraordinary that the Home
Secretary can't bring herself
can't bring herself can't bring herself
to condemn those illegal immigrants who
are breaking into our country in
flagrant breach of our laws that is weak
that is weak the truth is
that the labor party are too weak to
take the kind of tough decisions that we
are taking today and in their weakness
they would make the United Kingdom a
magnet there will be open doors an open
checkbook and there will be open season
for abuse the British public know that
the conservative party understand their
legitimate concerns they don't we don't
sneer at people for wanting basic border
controls we're taking the tough
decisions we will stop the boat we will
secure the borders
[Music]
although the minister did not mention
RAF scampton by name we assume that that
is the base in Lincolnshire he is
referring to
I can inform him that the moment this is
confirmed the local authority of West
Lindsay will issue an immediate judicial
review and injunction
against this thoroughly bad decision
which is not based on good governments
but the politics of trying to do
something how
to that we will not lose 300 million
pounds worth of regeneration already
agreed and signed between West Lindsay
and scampton holdings how they preserve
the listed buildings the Heritage Center
how do you preserve this Heritage of
dambusters and of the Red Arrows how can
he guarantee there's not contamination
from the fuel Bay of the Red Arrows how
would you protect the safety of 1 000
people living right next door to 1500
migrants and a primary school he can't
guarantee anything will he work with
West Lindsay now and Lincolnshire to try
and find an alternative site we are
prepared to do it but we do not want to
lose 300 million pounds of regeneration
Lincolnshire will fight and ligature
will be proved right
[Applause]
I could only I I could only pay I could
only pay tribute about adaptive speaker
to my right-humble friend and uh my
friend and constituency neighbor he is
representing his constituents forcefully
in the way he's always done in this
place and he's absolutely right to do so
I I can say to him that whilst this
policy is without question in the
National interest we understand the
impact and the concern that there will
be within local communities and all
parts of government want to work closely
with him with his local authorities to
mitigate the issues that will arise as a
result of this site I can say to him
that there will be a significant package
of support for his constituents there
will be specific protections for the
unique Heritage on the site we don't
intend to make any use of the historic
buildings and indeed in our temporary
use of the site to ensure that those
Heritage assets are in fact enhanced and
preserved we do see this as a short-term
Arrangement and we would like to enter
into an agreement as he knows with West
Lindsay District Council so that they
can take possession of the site at a
later date and their regeneration plans
which are extremely important for
Lincolnshire and the East Midlands more
generally can be realized in due course
I'll listen to
listen to you yeah thank you madam
Deputy speaker well Britain has
historical form in the use of internment
camps and is Despicable that this
government is intent on bringing them
back in 2023. it's pathetic attempt to
draw comparisons between the use of
cruise ships to accommodate ukrainians
is as offensive as it is misleading and
in fact yesterday the Ukrainian speaker
Ruslan servanchuk thanks Scotland for
saving the lives of his fellow citizens
Scotland is in fact standing down that
emergency humanitarian response Glasgow
was close to the Edinburgh has an end
date in sight and furthermore for those
cruise ships the Scottish government
provided wraparound support with local
government NHS schools and Community
integration his plan as a prison ship
designed as a deterrent yeah Alex
Wickham from Bloomberg reports that the
home office rejected a similar plan last
year as it would be even more expensive
than the eyewateringly expensive hotels
planned costing hundreds of thousands of
pounds per hour what has changed since
that advice last year private providers
are making a fortune out of this he is
now spending scandalously one-third of
the UK's International Aid Budget on
domestic Asylum costs so what impact has
this read on critical Aid had on the
push factors bringing people to these
Shores when was this when this idea was
previously proposed last year ministers
were also advised that security would be
a nightmare the project would be
expensive and it would amount to
arbitrary detention a breach of the UN
Refugee convention so what's changed in
this advice was given last year does he
understand that on a housing
unaccompanied minors or traumatized
people who have fled a war zone and
minute J style accommodation considered
unfit for the mod would be Gravely
inappropriate and would give assurances
that such individuals would be exempt
from such measures Madam Deputy speaker
the real problem here is the backlog we
all know that and the home office's
inability to tackle it he knows that
I've got constituents we think six
months 10 months 40 months 18 months 20
months and more for a decision from the
home office when will we stop wasting
money on headlines and instead tackle
the real crisis and fix the backlog well
under her first or one of her questions
regarding the use of overseas
development Aid to pay for the
accommodation of Asylum Seekers here in
the UK we entirely agree with her I I
think it is a gross waste of taxpayers
money and we want to see that money
being put to better usage and that's
exactly why we need to stop the boats so
the finite resources of the United
Kingdom can be applied either to
resettlement schemes where we bring
people from places of grave danger like
conflict zones directly or that we use
our resources to support people in some
of the most hard-pressed places in the
world that is obviously the best and
moral Way Forward rather than open
borders for predominantly young men in a
place of safety in France with respect
to vessels as I said in my statement we
do see merits in using them they have
been used successfully in Scotland it's
surprising that the SMP seek to
denigrate one of their own policies they
don't have very many successful policies
so when they have one you'd think that
they would uh want to particularly when
it comes to ferries let's be honest the
SMB are on shaky grounds with respect to
families we don't intend to put miners
or families on these sites but they are
the right way forward for single adult
males with respect to the backlog we are
making significant progress and well we
are actually The Honorable lady doesn't
like to deal with facts as we know but
the uh I can give her our internal uh
unpublished as yet figures uh which are
that over 11
000 over 11
000 cases in the backlog have been
processed in the last three months as a
result of the new processes we've took
in play we put in place but mandatory
the broader pointers we all know with
the SMP is that they have become sort of
humanitarian nimbers she takes she takes
the kind of Saint Augustine approach
Lord let us welcome refugees but not in
our constituencies
she would have more credibility
is and matched her fine words with good
deeds
[Music]
no no no no no no no no
[Applause]
no no no no no
we will just calm down before we go any
further thank you I I expect better from
over there
pretty Patel
respectfully make a few points to my
right humble friend
um the minister
um I think actually we need to tackle
this entire debate and discussion with a
degree of maturity actually this is a
very very difficult and sensitive
subject and if I made the points that I
would like to make very much refer to
previous policy new plan for immigration
Greek star reception centers had we have
had those in plays I think the minister
would recognize this we would not be in
this current situation I would just like
to ask the minister though very
specifically
um I am an Essex MP and I'm the other MP
for Braintree District
um Wethersfield is not in my
constituency it's in the constituency of
my Russian friend foreign secretary it
is no different if I may say so in terms
of the rurality and the village size to
a former site not in Essex which was
Linton on ooze which was canceled by the
current government can I ask why it is
deemed appropriate for uh Asylum Seeker
accommodation to be placed in rural
Village in Essex with single men where
there are no there's no infrastructure
no amenities but it was not appropriate
for someone like Linton
yeah well well firstly could I could I
pay tribute to my right honorable friend
who began this good work with her new
plan for immigration which was an
incredibly important step forward and
amongst other points that recognized
that it is absolutely critical that when
individuals cross the channel illegally
they are moved either to detained
accommodation which we want to bring
forward as a result of our bill or in
the absence of that to specific sites
where they can be housed appropriately
where their cases can be processed
swiftly and where they had minimal
impact on broader Society I know that
she pursued a very similar Prospect in
North Yorkshire and she will have
sympathy for the work that we've done in
recent months to take forward similar
proposals I can say that we don't have a
current plan to proceed with the Linton
on news proposition but the sites that
I've announced today are just the first
set that we'd like to take forward
because we want we want to remove people
from hotels as quickly as possible and
to move to this more rudimentary form of
accommodation which will reduce pull
factors to the UK and defend the
interests of the taxpayer Aleister
Carmike Deputy speaker I think the house
should be more generous to the minister
we should acknowledge the true genius of
this announcement only this home office
team could think that the answer to the
problem of growing numbers of people in
small boats was to take them all
together and put them into one big boat
Armando yanucci himself couldn't improve
on that but if the minister is confident
in his projections about what is going
to happen to the backlog of Asylum
applications why is this extra capacity
going to be necessary
well to answer the the second Point
first what we want to see is anyone
crossing the channel moves into this
kind kind of rudimentary accommodation
immediately and so it's absolutely
critical that we build National capacity
so that we can clear the hotels consign
that policy uh to the history books and
then people are put into these large
sites that's why we need them I have
affection for the the right honorable
gentleman but I'm afraid he is being
naive in this regard because I am
speaking every day as is the Home
Secretary to our northern European
counterparts in Ireland in Belgium and
Denmark and France they are all pursuing
options like this because there is a
European migration crisis we have to
ensure that the UK is not a magnet for
those individuals who are either
economic migrants or are essentially
Asylum Shoppers I will not allow the UK
to be a soft touch
Deputy speaker the determination of the
government to accelerate the processing
of claims is to be welcomed
my right honorable friend I think would
agree that it is unacceptable wrong and
immoral the people have their lives on
hold unable to make a new future for
themselves or indeed to be returned to
their countries of origin
Madam Deputy speaker we have a number of
hotels in my Bournemouth West
constituency are full of such people who
are constantly in touch with my
hard-working casework team who want
their cases resolved so too I say to my
right honorable friend do those involved
in the hospitality and Leisure sector in
Bournemouth on which our economy Depend
and local residents who want to see
those hotels brought back into the
purpose of serving our thriving
Hospitality sector in Bournemouth can my
right honorable friend give me the
assurance that the proposals he is
announcing today will bring into cite
the day when those hotels will be
returned to that purpose well my
writable friend raises exactly the
concerns that have motivated us to bring
forward these proposals we want to
ensure that the interests of his
constituency and constituents are put
above those of illegal immigrants coming
into our country this is the necessary
first step to build National capacity in
these new forms of accommodation so that
we can begin to close the hotels and
move forwards
so George
for the discussions we he held recently
with the leader chief executive and
myself of knowsley council to discuss
the problem we have with the hotel in my
constituency
um he's a were
that in my view the use of hotels is not
fair on a taxpayer it's not fair on
local communities and nor is it uh
suitable for the refugees themselves
will he though give me
some indication of what criteria will we
use to determine which hotels close and
in what sequence
well the conversations that I had with
the right honorable gentleman and his
local Authority leaders informed the
decisions that we've taken because it
was very clear from his constituency
that that hotel was inflaming Community
tensions that many people thought it was
wrong that uh illegal migrants were
being housed in a much regarded facility
that was a hotel that was used for
weddings and and social events and that
we need to bring that to a close when we
have the capacity to begin closing
hotels at PACE I think we'll do so
through a number of lenses obviously
closing the most egregious cases first
where the cost to local communities is
highest uh also those were in locations
which were clearly unsuitable to begin
with such as Seaside towns and so on and
then also those where the contracts are
coming to an end and we wouldn't want to
renew them for value for money purposes
Richard Drex
Deputy speaker
land-based reception camps in the right
place has to be the solution
does our elephant agree me that
if you look at what happened in hotels
so far with illegal immigrants we've had
all kinds of issues with local residents
disappearing children sexual assaults
etc etc etc etc so would you agree with
me that putting these people on boats or
on barges where the problem is going to
be exacerbated tenfold is totally and
utterly out of the question
well there are no easy answers these are
amongst the most difficult decisions
within government but I do think that
placing Asylum Seekers on well-run large
sites with specific facilities uh
provided
holding having minimal impact upon local
communities is the right approach taking
hotels in a relatively ad hoc fashion in
town centers on high streets is not the
right way forward with respect to
vessels such as barges or ferrers I do
see Merit in that it is an approach
that's been pursued uh in Scotland but
also and in particular i i i i reference
the Netherlands which is using them
effectively and it does provide good
value for money and decent accommodation
Patrick great
don't you speak of the big help out
encourages people to volunteer for a
good cause over the coronation weekend
and a number of opportunities listed on
it including with the British Red Cross
are other organizations that help
refugees and Asylum Seekers so does he
think it's appropriate that people spend
a coronation weekend uh supporting
people who he says have broken into this
country
[Applause]
well he and I may may disagree on that
the fundamental Point here but I believe
in borders
I believe in National Security and
National sovereignty and those people
who choose to enter our country in
flagrant abuse of our laws who in many
cases throw their documents into the
channel those people are breaking the
law and it is right that we take action
against them and where possible remove
them from our country Michael long
I'm Deputy speaking if I may quickly
welcome her back to the chair it's been
a while
um will the minister agree with me that
whilst the government accelerates
assessment enforcement and removal that
it is quite right that we look at
suitable and sustainable accommodation
for illegal immigrants and will he also
agree with me therefore that if Armed
Force bases are suitable for our brave
they are certainly suitable for illegal
immigration
well he's right to say that there is a a
peculiarity on the left of politics that
they seem to be happy to house our
braved Armed Forces Personnel on these
sites but not to see illegal immigrants
temporarily housed there whilst we
process their claims of course we will
always be motivated by decency and
legality these sites will be well run
and appropriate but we mustn't allow a
further pull factor to the UK to emerge
Hillary Ben
CH indeed Madam Deputy speaker the
writerable gentleman told the house a
little earlier that the three sites
which we presume are RAF scampton RAF
weathers field and deciding East Sussex
Pepsi care to name it will house provide
accommodation for several thousand could
he tell the house how many thousand in
doing so could he remind us of the total
number of people who are being placed in
hotels currently
well the number of individuals who will
be housed on the sites will step up
obviously we want to ensure that the
sites are well managed and so initially
they'll be smaller numbers but within a
very short period of time there will be
several thousand on those sites
um I I'm not going to give those details
to the right home gentleman now because
it's right that we engage with the local
authorities and that they be the first
to know the full details of our plans
but they will be a very significant
addition to our capacity the point he's
making is that in addition to that there
is a very large number of people
currently accommodated in hotels but
this is the first step this is the first
step on the road to clearing those
hotels and moving forwards I would just
say one further point which is it's
abundantly clear to me having spent four
months in this role now there is no way
in which I or the British government can
build our way out of this issue there
are tens of thousands of people entering
our country in an irregular manner every
year
of course we have to get our own
processes and play and management
processes in place but we've got to stop
people coming here in the first place
that's why we're bringing forward the
bill
thank you through
okay and I welcome today's update and
commend my rightful friends for the
efforts he's put in to get us to this
stage
further to the repeat assurance that
I've previously received from the
dispatch bot from both my writable
friend and the prime minister
with the minister now commit to
publishing a clear timetable for the
closure of the two Margaret hotels
within touch and distance of each other
in our wash in weeks not months and when
they guarantee this will be the end of
their use for such purposes
well I know that uh the right honorable
lady my honorable friend has been very
tenacious in campaigning on behalf of
her constituents who as I said in my
statement more broadly are extremely
concerned about the impact these hotels
are having and a lot of amenity in terms
of business and tourism and and social
events is for that reason that we're
taking this difficult but correct
decision to produce these sites and I
hope that we'll start to see hotels
coming to a close in the months ahead
and I'd be delighted to work with her as
we do so
the British taxpayer is shelling out
over 6 million pounds a day to house
migrants but Asylum decisions have
collapsed by 40 since 2015 and that is
what is to blame for the chaos with
hotels how and furthermore a damning
watchdog report found that the home
office didn't have
financial information to
whether those contracts were valued for
money and they didn't even follow the
correct procedure as was laid out so
Minister after 13 years is there
anything that this government can manage
to do properly well we all know what
state the last Labor government left the
home office in and we only have to refer
as I did the other day to the reporter
of John Vine who was the uh the
inspector at the time which painted a
picture of complete chaos and
dysfunction at the home office when uh
the party opposite were last in power
it is important it
you know we get the backlog down
from what I've said today that I have
put in place a robust plan and that we
have a high degree of confidence that we
will succeed in getting it down over the
course of this year but the real issue
is the number of people crossing the
channel the people Smugglers the human
traffickers if we clear the backlog if
we make it even faster to process
people's claims that won't stop people
cut you know that's not going to stop
the boats that's a fantasy
stopping the boats requires tougher
measures than that like those set out in
the illegal migration bill
Ed Gibson
just speaking circumstances in which my
right honorable friend would envisage
children being placed in any of the
sites that he's announced today and to
ensure that they can be moved into local
Authority care as swiftly as possible
could I encourage him to use the
additional funding which is welcome and
been announced for councils to cope with
this accommodation that they have an
incentive to make sure that that is
available to children as a priority
it's not my intention to house miners on
these sites it's right that we ensure
that Miners and families are properly
supported these sites are going to be
used for single adult males and will act
as a serious deterrent to those people
coming to this country
Joanna Cherry thank you madam Deputy
speaker these report proposals are
highly reminiscent of the internment
camps for refugees and the BBC series
the years and years which was on during
lockdown and if you didn't see it Madam
Deputy speaker it was really about the
decline of modern Britain and ended with
the election of a fascist populist prime
minister Ukrainian refugees in Scotland
have been temporarily accommodated in
high quality former Ferry accommodation
at Leith docks which is adjacent to my
constituency and I've visited it and I
suggest if the minister were to visit it
he would see it's extremely different
from the industrial barges he's uh
proposing but those were temporary
accommodations does he appreciate
dumps refugees from other countries into
the sort of poor quality accommodation
that he's describing the United Kingdom
May face a claim of racial
discrimination under article 14 of the
echr here here
um well I refer to the The Honorable age
the comments I made earlier as we know
the Scottish government did use ferries
uh I passed no criticism of the of the
Scottish government uh for their choice
of doing so and appears to have worked
uh relatively successfully in the
circumstances and so I think it is it is
an option worthy of consideration uh
with respect to meeting our our domestic
and international law obligations of
course we intend to do so and any
accommodation we bring forward will be
decent and legal
Natalia
my conservative left Dover district
council has been working really hard to
provide affordable and other housing for
local people Kent County Council
likewise for local services but that
excellent work is put under immense
pressure in having to deal with the
sheer numbers and volume of uh of of
migrants within Kent
um this has been supported by the labor
party who don't want to stop the small
votes and who care more about Channel
migrants than they do about the
residents of Dover and deal here in
spite of the pressures on services and
on schools we are being asked to do more
and take more and today's announcement
will not ease those pressures on Kent in
that regard well my right honorable
friend meet with me and Kent colleagues
to see what more can be done to ease the
pressures the immense pressures that are
faced in Kent and particularly in Dover
and deal well I'd be pleased to meet my
honorable friend and her colleagues once
again I'm acutely aware of the pressures
faced by Kent and by local authorities
in Kent and not only will this policy
reduce the dependence upon hotels it
will ensure that farts further
significantly increased funding is made
available to local authorities such as
hers so that that can alleviate some of
the burdens they're facing
Ruth Cadbury thank you madam Deputy
speaker the minister knows that while
Asylum Seekers are living in often very
difficult conditions in the hotels a
large proportion of taxpayers funding
isn't even going to the hotels or the
food providers but it's hemorrhaging out
into the pockets of a network of often
dodgy contractors and subcontractors
what's he doing to address this
mismanagement of government funds well I
now meet very regularly with exactly uh
those firms our home office providers
and she can be assured in fact I think
I've I've said this to her privately
that I have been very clear with those
companies that they have a job to do we
need them to find suitable accommodation
but the accommodation must be good
quality must meet our contractual terms
and there must be value for money
they've been left in absolutely no doubt
of My Views and if she or any other
member of this house have concerns or
criticisms they should bring them to me
and I will sure that they are heard
Kelly tolhurst
speaker and it's just nice to see you
back in your place
um I do thank the my right honorable
friend for the hard work that he has
um well shown he's shown me the the
strength for the work that he's been
doing over the months he's been in the
roles to try and tackle the problem and
um I very much encourage his
determination to stop the boats
um I'm very pleased to see that we have
uh had more enforcement uh work and also
that the funding for local authorities
is is is coming forward this is
something that is very key for any local
authorities that are dealing with Asylum
Seekers
um but I would like to just touch on the
dispersal accommodation element and
really a plea that when the home office
are making decisions around where to put
dispersal accommodation that where there
is age where there are agencies who
agree that a place is inappropriate that
the agencies who are put foreign that
information the home office should
really take note of that and look for
alternative sites for those types of
accommodation yeah well my right or
friend has been vociferous in raising
legitimate concerns about one particular
location in her constituency she's right
to say that there should be appropriate
engagement between the local Authority
and the home office before any decisions
are made that the police and other
stakeholders should be informed and
where there are serious concerns of
course we shouldn't proceed with those
properties
foreign speaker the minister was right
when he said we need to stop people
coming here by boats but last night
labor voted for a cross-border police
unit in the National Crime agency to
Target criminal gangs smuggling people
across the channel this is a measure
that would make a huge difference in the
short term and the long term to
protecting our borders and the welfare
of migrants why on Earth did the
government's MPS vote against it because
we've already done it
Jane Stevenson imagine Deputy speaker I
want to pay tribute to my right
honorable friend I know him to be a
compassionate fair-minded Minister and
he is having to take extremely difficult
decisions in balancing helping people
who are the most vulnerable and the
interests of the people who elect us to
represent them in this place the UK
taxpayer does he agree with me that the
failure of parties opposite to recognize
that during such a migration crisis
there has to be a sensible limit on
numbers and the refusal to admit that
resources are limited and UK taxpayers
money is limited makes them unfit for
office
The Honorable lady raised a very
important and fundamental point that of
course we want the United Kingdom to be
a generous and compassionate country
that is renowned across the world the
way in which we treat those seeking
Sanctuary but we also have to appreciate
the finite resources that we have we
have to deploy them in the most
effective active Manner and that I feel
profoundly that we're sent here not to
grandstand or to Virtue signal but to
put the well-being and interest of our
own constituents first
the ministers made vague statements
about all Asylum seek has been moved out
of hotels
he hasn't got a plan how to do it has he
the only fall back as the security
minister well let's see it the only the
only fall back with the security
minister announced yesterday is to pass
responsibility back to local authorities
did he see the response from the local
government Association yesterday to that
plan where they said that most councils
have got no social housing to offer in
most areas the local housing allowance
isn't sufficient to pay for the cost of
accommodation so what does the expected
authorities to do when thousands of
Asylum Seekers are simply passed back to
them from the hotels they're currently
in
that The Honorable gentleman always
campaigns against the building of new
homes that might have been the easiest
way to fix the housing crisis but what
we're going to do is work carefully and
productively with local authorities to
address this issue that's always been my
Approach when I was local government
secretary I engaged constantly
religiously with local Authority leaders
and we're continuing to do so what we're
going to do is provide significantly
enhanced resources to them so that we
better meet the true costs of handling
this difficult challenge
Tom Hunt
we can clearly uh basic and cheap
accommodation is far better than
four-star hotels at the heart of
communities to accommodate those who've
illegally entered our country the
minister will know how strongly I feel
about the Nova Hotel nips which and also
affected the vast majority of my
constituents are against it it's
interesting that the labor party today
has said they oppose use of Hotel
accommodation because only recently we
had a protest in favor of the use of a
hotel which was attended by the labor
parliamentary candidate and half a local
labor party so that's quite interesting
will a minister be able to give me some
time scales with regards to when we can
move out those who are currently in
hotels into more appropriate
accommodations because the sooner we get
out of an old hotel the better and the
more support he'll get from our
constituents
well I I share his desire to close that
hotel as as soon as possible I know how
hard he's been representing his
constituents in this regard today is the
critical First Step once we have these
sites up and running a combination of
new arrivals and those currently in
hotels will be moved on to the sites the
backlog clearance will of course free up
places in in hotels and enable us to
close those but the fundamental point is
that the only sustainable answer is to
stop the boats in the first place
strip one Donald
yeah sure Madam speaker can I ask what
assessment the department has made of
the increased risk of self-harm and
indeed suicide amongst vulnerable Asylum
Seekers placed in precisely the type of
institutional accommodation that he is
advocating for today has a risk
assessment been done of this policy
perhaps even won the MPS are allowed to
see
well of course we take the well-being of
the illegal immigrants the residents of
these new sites seriously I think that
they will be better cared for in this
bespoke accommodation than in a network
of ad hoc hotels taken in emergency
circumstances these sites will have
well-trained individuals running them
they'll have their own health care
facilities and we'll be able to have
home office Personnel on-site processing
their claims swiftly so they can either
be granted Asylum and remain in the UK
begin paying taxes make a contribution
to our country or be removed
Dr Neil Hudson
thank you madam Deputy speaker can I
thank the minister for his update and
for his hard work in this area can my
right Umbra friend reassure this house
that the treatment of women Children and
Families throughout this whole process
will be compassionate and that
throughout the entire process that this
conservative government is committed to
supporting and bolstering safe and legal
routes to help vulnerable people fleeing
persecution and seeking Sanctuary
firstly he has my total assurance that
whilst this policy is tough it will also
be decent and legal and he can see the
work that I did in the autumn in the
reforms to the manston site in Kent as
evidence of the way in which I will
approach this but to his second Point
absolutely this government believes in
the UK being a world leader for
resettlement schemes and safe and legal
routes which we are already
500 000 people have come to our country
for humanitarian purposes since 2015
that's something we should be proud of
and it's something that a conservative
government will continue
Tim Howard the deputy speaker he
referenced um and misquoted Saint
Augustine of Hippo earlier on who was
from North Africa and he would have put
him in a camp as a consequence and he
talked also in his statement about
fundamentally altering our posture I
wonder if the minister might consider
altering his posture to being one of
someone who is good at his job because
in the end what we have got is Asylum
seekers in hotels who do not want to be
in hotels but are in hotels and hostels
why because of the Colossal backlog that
this government is responsible for
rather than wasting money on this
gimmick today which clearly many of his
back Ventures disagree with for a
variety of different reasons why does he
not invest in making sure that those
appeals are heard quickly those hearings
are done quickly so people can either be
given the right to remain or be removed
as his government is failing to do what
do you agree with me there is one thing
worse than his and his governments
incompetent on this issue and it is the
blaming of the consequences of that
incompetence on the most vulnerable
people in the world
yeah well I fundamentally disagree with
the right honorable gentleman fault here
lies with the people Smugglers and the
human traffickers we should never blame
ourselves in this country for the
actions of organized immigration
criminals that is completely wrong we
are taking robust action to stop the
boat to arrest the trade which is
bringing tens of thousands of people
illegally into our country and putting
people's lives on the line every day he
doesn't want that of course he doesn't
that's why he should support our bill
and help us to stop the boats
Chuck Burton
thank you speakers the minister knows
Stoke on Trent has contributed
significantly to accommodating both
Asylum Seekers and refugees and the
announcements today of additional
funding for local areas will be very
welcome to help cope with some of those
pressures but my constituents in
Stoke-on-Trent want to know will the
minister be prioritizing emptying those
hotels
that Stoke on Trent has
um stepped up and has provided a
significant amount of accommodation and
that is creating challenges for the city
it's been my pleasure to work with him
and the uh the excellent leader of so
content city council we want to ensure
that hotels that are the most egregious
cases are closed the first and I think
in particular of the the north stats
hotel in the the center of stoke that is
exactly the sort of important business
asset that I'd like to see close swiftly
Andy Slaughter thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker in the far past few weeks
Asylum figures have been placed in
hotels in my constituency that the home
office then deemed unfit for occupation
and dispersed them to undisclosed
locations and no notice children have
been taken out of school in the middle
of exams and last night I'm told that
Asylum Seekers were dumped outside the
hotel in Shepherd's Bush and told to
share rooms and beds with complete
strangers is it the government's policy
to punish and humiliate Asylum seekers
in these ways as a means of discouraging
further migrants even though on past
experience the majority are likely to be
granted status in the UK
we'll always treat people with decency
and compassion but it's also correct
that we have to address the very
significant pull factor to the United
Kingdom this is an approach being
followed by most of our North European
neighbors like the belgiums the Dutch
the Danes the French and the Irish
because the pressures are so great he
doesn't want to stop the boats he
doesn't back our bill or indeed any
prior measures we want to we'll take the
steps that are necessary Celine Saxby
you missed a deputy speaker and can I
take the opportunity to thank my right
honorable friend for all of his work in
this area because I think most of us
recognize this is a multifaceted problem
and there is no Silver Bullet solution
can I ask does today's announcement mean
that there will not be further requests
by contractors to find hotel
accommodation or similar as I am aware
of challenging conversations in my own
constituency at this time and where we
are looking to empty hotels we have a
community that's very willing to welcome
people into their homes but might we
look towards a scheme the same as we did
when coming Ukrainian refugees where
there is additional ministerial resource
not disrespectful of his own experience
in this matter so that we can actually
bridge that Gap with um the leveling up
Department because we have a housing
crisis of my our own we have thousands
of our own population unable to secure
accommodation but we are Keen to work to
find a solution and might there be an
opportunity to sort of bridge the
housing and the immigration situation
uh well we are trying to work as closely
as possible the home office and the
department for leveling up my honorable
friend the member for Kensington is
working closely with us on the operation
of schemes like homes for Ukraine the
Ukraine family scheme the Afghan schemes
uh Syria and so on that's very important
we also have officials who are working
jointly between the two departments so I
hope that she will see that all of
government is working closely together
to address this complex multifaceted
challenge
like that hood
thanks everybody speaker the minister
has told us that newly arrived migrants
are going to be taken to this new form
of accommodation so they are going to be
competing for places with people who
wants to move out of hotels and it seems
to me that he's planning for the failure
of his
illegal attempts through legislation to
stop boats because he's increasing the
capacity of the spaces that he is is
planning so can he tell us in addition
to those that are already accommodated
by the home office how many more people
is he planning to accommodate
uh well I'm confused by this question he
doesn't support the bill in the first
place but it is Our intention that once
we have secured the passage of our bill
through Parliament I thought the
committee stage over the last two days
showed the strength of support on this
side of uh the house not not quite the
same reaction on the other side but
we're going to bring forward the Rwanda
proposal once that is operationalized
people will be detained uh their cases
will be heard in a limited fashion and
then they'll be removed from the country
swiftly in the meantime we need some
capacity and that's going to be provided
by these new large sites
Mr rag
very much Mr Deputy speaker my
reasonable friend is one of the able
ministers in the home office so it makes
sense for him to give this statement
um this afternoon is he though as
concerned as I am with a Gerald Ratner
approach to the government's immigration
policy whereby it simply spends its time
highlighting the problems rather than
some of the work it is undertaking
is he aware that the primary concern for
most people is to ensure that the
backlog of Asylum applications is dealt
with at a pace at which and decisions
more importantly as they were in 2015.
uh could I also caution hinder even
worse than a Gerald Ratner approach to
government policy on this is a something
must seem to be done policy which might
bring forward this rosian gym idea of
barges uh all over the place
uh well the my honorable friend uh
raises an important point that I think
the public uh do not want to see
performative or declaratory policies in
this space they want to see us acting
taking difficult decisions and that is
what is within this statement he's also
correct to say that this requires a
approach across many different Avenues
and he can see that again in the fact
that we are rapidly reducing the backlog
that we've increased immigration
enforcement visits by 50 that we've
established the small boats operational
command in the channel and recruiting
hundreds of officers to staff that there
we've signed deals with France Albania
this shows the government acting on
every approach he can be a no doubt we
will solve this problem and if we fail
it will not be the one to try
Mr Ferry thank you Minister talked about
only meeting the basic needs of of the
residents however at mental health to
many people is a basic need I don't see
how isolation is going to help in that
particular regard
um following on from that can I invite
the minister to join me in condemning
the racist protesters that are appearing
outside hotels including one in my own
consistency and then particular invite
him to directly challenge the tropes
that have been used that Asylum Seekers
are sexual predators the same tactic has
been used down through the centuries to
attack marginalized people
been very clear that those far right and
other elements who are inciting violence
and intimidation outside hotels or other
forms of accommodation are wrong I have
directed the home office to work closely
with the police through the National
Police coordination Center and other
parts of government including the
security services to track that
pernicious activity and to support local
councils and police forces in taking
robust action wherever possible if he
has a particular case he wants to bring
to my attention I'd be pleased to look
into them Chucky doll price thank you uh
Mr Deputy speaker can I just probe a
friend with regards to his proposals for
for housing markets in barges and
ferries and specifically could you just
advise whether he expects those vessels
to be uh to have access to the key or
moored offshore and if they are to have
access to the key which I'd expect what
conversations he's had with Port
operators about the operational
challenges to their business for hosting
what is this essentially a residential
Community long term
well my honorable friend will forgive me
I'm not going to comment on press
speculation I I will obviously make
further statements should we proceed uh
with any significant developments in
this regard I have pointed to examples
in Scotland and in the Netherlands where
the use of vessels has been successful
we don't as she knows currently have the
powers to detain individuals for
prolonged periods of time and so any
form of accommodation would be
non-detained
or Bloomfield you very much Mr Deputy
speaker
in response to an earlier question the
minister talked about people breaking
into our country
the Home Secretary has talked about an
invasion
Words which I guess like this statement
are designed for the headlines
but
genuinely whether he doesn't recognize
that this sort of language does describe
people
many of whom are seeking Refuge from
countries like Afghanistan Iran and
Syria
whether such languages inflammatory
divisive adding to the sort of tensions
other members have talked about and
whether he wouldn't reflect on his use
of language and agree that the priority
is to tackle the people's Smugglers not
criminalize and demonize their victims
well I believe that all of us have a
responsibility to choose our words with
care and to accept the occasions where
we choose the wrong language this is an
area of public policy which it would be
better to de-escalate the current
language and tensions I don't think that
it's wrong to describe individuals as
illegal immigrants or to say that
individuals are breaking into our
country because we have borders
and they have to be enforced if you or I
crossed a national border into another
country you would expect to be met by
law enforcement and a robust response
mark jenkinson thank you Mr Deputy
speaker can I pay a tribute to the work
of my original friend on this matter and
that of the Home Secretary and the
former Home Secretary the diligence and
cooperation of each of them with me has
been welcome over the last 12 months
um last summer I successfully managed to
stop
um the introduction of a hotel in my
constituency of workington in a wholly
unsuitable Place uh although it fell on
me unfortunately to prove to the home
office that it was fully unsuitable the
threat of additional hotels not only of
hotels but of companies like Circle
hoovering up family homes while we have
a housing waiting list in my
constituency remains can my writable
friend set out to me what today's
announcement means for that threat and
when we can safely say that threat might
have been removed
for his uh his generous words towards me
and my colleagues at the home office he
he's right to say that the sheer number
of people crossing the channel illegally
coupled with the generosity of our
country in recent years in welcoming in
500 000 people on humanitarian ground
and the high levels of legal migration
we have opposing a very serious
challenge to communities and councils
with respect to housing and social
housing we're working with the
department for leveling up through those
challenges and a one additional element
that we're introducing today is a
substantially enhanced package for local
authorities so they have more funding to
pay for the kinds of accommodation that
they'll need and any displacement
activity that might occur Shepherd
thank you Mr Deputy speaker
um rather than treat those seeking
sanctuary in these shores as criminals
and waste vast sums of money to build
internment camps to house them wouldn't
it be more sensible simply to issue them
with temporary workplace so that they
can contribute to the community earn
their own money to cover their own
housing costs and pay tax into the
exchecker rather than being a drain upon
it exactly yeah
I understand the and and acknowledge
that that's a legitimate point of view
it's not one that I agree with because I
believe that we have to suffuse our
approach with deterrence and if we allow
a further pull factor to the United
Kingdom in the form of enabling people
to work soon after their arrival I
suspect we will just find even more
people coming to this country
Jonathan gullis thank you Mr Deputy
speaker I want to first of all thank my
role and friendly Minister for his
engagement which has been quite robust
between us at times because he'll
understand that in Stoke on Trent where
we have around 1300 Asylum Seekers and
illegal economic migrants of which 31
are in hotels
residents and constituents are outraged
to see the city used and abused in this
way and he wholly and accurately
reflects the North Stafford hotel right
by a leveling up project right by a 40
million pound transforming cities fund
right opposite our railway station which
is a gateway to six million visitors a
year as being wholly unacceptable so to
seek reconfirmation Mr Speaker from one
friend who's asked who ain't answer to
my friend and neighbor in slope on Trent
South that Stoke-on-Trent will be one of
those priority areas that we'll see
these young single men moved out of
hotels into the new accommodation he is
outlined today
well as my other friend knows I I love
the potteries and we always want to
further the best interest of stoke on
Trent and its wider region uh the hotel
uh By The Station is a particularly
egregious one in my opinion because it
is holding back regeneration uh in that
part of the city and I would like to see
it closed at the earliest opportunity
the other point I'd make with regards to
Stoke-on-Trent is that it has stepped up
and taken a very large number of
individuals through dispersal
accommodation uh which I hope other
local authorities will do with the added
support we're providing today
Simon Lakewood thank you Mr Deputy
speaker yesterday labor offered a
reasonable Amendment to the illegal
migration bill which would have forced
the home office to consult with councils
over Asylum hotels that would have been
welcome in my constituency where despite
The Minister's announcements it's
planning to force a third Hotel on my
community Wakefield Council has already
had 300 million pounds cut from its
budget and so it's best to provide
support but it lacks the community
capacity and yes the funding to do more
so why did the government run scared
last night and vote down our amendment
to give local councils a say
well he should go back to his
constituents and explain why in his
short tenure in this house he has
already started voting against exactly
the kind of measures which would stop
the boats I rather suspect that he's not
on the same side as his constituents on
this issue Foster
Hugh Mr Deputy speaker and as we said
today's statement is one that you know I
can understand The Minister's
trepidation in coming into the dispatch
because having had to do similar
statements myself over the years but it
is the right approach that he's
outlining uh today we can see
comparisons particularly on Continental
Europe particularly in Greece where
large-scale accommodation centers being
used as part of a transformation of
their site their Asylum system providing
Humane and decent accommodation was also
actually assisting with the process of
making uh decisions now in terms of
dealing with some of the issues we've
had thrown at this one I'm assuming he
will view this as a part of national
infrastructure and therefore take that
through that planning process and the
second part of this I also presume this
is all as he touched on already
non-detained accommodation and then
finally what sort of timeline is he
looking to actually get some of these
centers up and running because people
will only really see the this making a
difference when they see hotels closing
down in their local area
well my honorable friend knows how
difficult these decisions can be and
like him as my predecessor I didn't come
into politics to deal with clandestine
entry or organized immigration crime but
I did go into politics to provide
security and stability to the public and
to put the interests of my constituents
above those of anyone else and that's
why we're taking these decisions in the
National interest we will ensure these
sites are non-detained they're legally
compliant they'll be provided at PACE we
will make use of the planning powers
that the government has at its disposal
and I'm confident that we'll be able to
get individuals on these sites in the
coming weeks
to hear Ali
speaker
13 years of touring mismanagement Asylum
system in crisis backlogs out of control
claims not being decided for years on
end this statement does nothing but
bring a scare mongering and headline
grabbing just before the local elections
a member of his own party summarized
this statement quite correctly as
politics of trying to do something
really agree with me that this statement
which is no more than headline grabbing
scaremongering does very little to
Target human traffickers and the illegal
grants but rather it it makes illegal
traffickers the heroes whilst the
victims are the real Targets in this
better than the politics of doing
nothing which is what the opposition is
proposing we are taking action to tackle
the people Smugglers and the human
traffickers and I don't doubt the
motivations of The Honorable gentleman
but let me say this I see these people
and the work that they do every day in
this job they are some of the most evil
the most pernicious people in society
you have to match them you cannot behave
in a way which is weak and naive you
have to respond you have to respond with
tough policies and that's what we're
doing here we will not allow the UK to
be a soft touch and by ensuring that we
now have this new form of accommodation
not only will we clear the hotels but
we'll also ensure that there isn't a
pull factor to the UK Banks thank you Mr
Deputy speaker I warmly welcome the my
right honorable friends statement
um this afternoon and I'd also like to
take this opportunity to pay tribute to
the right honorable lady the member for
with them for her excellent work as Home
Secretary previously
um could my right honorable friend
comment in more detail on the similar
approach that's being taken to Asylum
accommodation by Belgium Ireland France
Germany and it would seem by the
Scottish government as well
well it is true as I've said a number of
occasions there are northern European
neighbors are looking to take similar
robust approaches uh in Ireland they are
considering uh bailing individuals to no
fixed Abode with vouchers to pay for
their immediate needs as as I understand
it uh in Belgium they have seen tented
communities arise and are using hostels
akin to homeless shelters the Danes have
I think publicly said that my writing or
friends policy with respect to Rwanda is
an interesting and valuable one which
they are looking on with interest and so
we're not alone we're not unique we're
working together because there is a
European migration crisis and we have to
take serious and robust decisions make
difficult choices or I'm afraid the UK
will be very exposed
can I thank the minister for his
statement today the minister knows there
is a difference between economic
migrants who are abusing the system and
are fit and independent and whose
circumstances have dictated the final
report but alongside there are those who
are Asylum Seekers money fleeing
religious persecution uh be it women
children families who need help urgently
so can I ask them answer this question
will he make it abundantly clear that
those who come here illegally due to
extending circumstances will have a
scope for compassion in their treatment
what we want to ensure that human
dignity is at the heart of the system
that we are creating and that's why the
UK has a fantastic record in recent
years for resettlement schemes of the
kind that I know that the honorable
gentleman is a champion like those from
Ukraine Hong Kong Syria Afghanistan and
by bringing an end to Illegal migration
across the channel or reducing it as far
as one can we can deploy our finite
resources as a country to help those
people who need it the most those people
who are in Conflict zones the victims of
religious persecution that he cares
passionately about rather than those
people who are predominantly young men
who are fit able and in a safe place
like France
can I thank um in a moment can I thank
the minister for his statement in
responding to questions for well over an
hour because I just ask him to remain
seated for the first point of order
which I think directly relates to
something that he may have said so Mr
bets
yeah with regard to The Minister's
response to the question I asked him
where he said I'd always opposed house
building I hope the minister knows in
this house as chair of the select
committee as well as individually I've
argued very strongly for more house
building including hitting the 300 000
targets only this week I've been working
with officers in Sheffield to try and
get away a scheme to build 800 homes
attitude Ward side in my constituency
I've worked on it for many years I've
known in the past the minister to be a
fair and reasonable man even when I
disagree with him wouldn't he on
reflection accepted what he said was
unfair and inaccurate and maybe like to
correct the record
well Mr Deputy speaker I've worked
alongside the honorable for some time
and I know him to be an excellent chair
of the select committee so I mean him no
disrespect he and I did disagree on
reforms of the planning system including
building more homes in Sheffield but I
know that he is a champion of good
quality housing and increasing a
quantity of it across the country